[Musica]
ci sono molte definizioni che cercano di
riassumere quale sia il ruolo di un
designer
all'interno di un sistema di produzione
industriale ma il ruolo del designer di
per sé mutevole cambia con con
l'avanzare dei tempi e delle tecnologie
come in realtà cambia anche l'industria
una cosa che è rimasta costante negli
anni
nella mia esperienza di designer e che
il nostro ruolo è come quello di un
ingranaggio all'interno di un sistema
complesso fatto di tante figure tutte
fondamentali che insieme ai partecipano
alla sedimentazione di sapere per creare
oggetti e prodotti sempre più
sofisticati
sedimentazione è una parola molto
importante
una parola che ci fa pensare a come alla
cultura come una specie di pulviscolo
che accumulandosi crea un terreno un
terreno che all'inizio molto fragile ma
che poi diventa via via passare del
tempo con l'accumularsi dell'esperienza
sempre più solido e creare una specie di
strada per i progettisti del futuro
effettivamente la sedimentazione del
sapere è una cosa importante perché
l'uomo diciamo che prende un po dalla
natura è una cosa che ci viene ci viene
da dalla natura lavorare insieme
guardiamo a sinistra l'immagine delle
formiche le formiche cosa fanno
va avanti la prima formica e cerca di
dare dell'informazione delle formiche
che vengono dietro
dicendo riguarda qui c'è del cibo qui
c'è un pericolo
invece se guardiamo le immagini di
destra è molto interessante perché
vediamo come in realtà con zoom
differenti abbiamo delle immagini molto
simili sono degli aerei è un'immagine
presa da
flightradar24
scono i piloti che vengono dietro quale
il percorso migliore se c'è una tempesta
se ci stanno delle dei problemi
possibili quindi questa cosa è molto
interessante perché ci fa capire che
anche utilizzando delle tecnologie noi
comunque rimaniamo attaccati alla natura
questa immagine molto forte da questo
punto di vista
effettivamente l'uomo
ha sempre progettato in in comune ha
progettato in compagnia e creando dei
gruppi di lavoro
questa è un'immagine del neolitico
un'immagine dipinta sulla pietra nel
sarà centrale mostra come già nelle
tribù lavorassero insieme per creare
delle armi già a quei tempi per la
caccia chiaramente a presenti gli
oggetti erano oggetti necessari alla
vita aiutavano a sopravvivere la
sopravvivenza
immagino già le persone a quel tempo che
si davano dei suggerimenti ok
utilizziamo un legno più flessibile per
l'arco legno più rigido per le frecce e
queste idee via via si sedimentano e
creano degli oggetti che arrivarono
esempio più perfezionati degli strumenti
che oggi utilizziamo in maniera
totalmente diversa mathieu realtà
partono da lontano
questo che vedete è un prodotto
interessante io mia moglie abbiamo avuto
da poco un bambino e abbiamo casa piena
di biberon questo è un biberon del 1200
avanti cristo e vedete come già a quei
tempi
c'era una ricerca non soltanto
funzionale ma anche formale cioè se
cercare di dare al bambino
già una forma che va tra esse che crei
che creasse con l'oggetto un feeling
oltre che una funzione questi oggetti
qua di questi oggetti se ne trovano già
dal neolitico
quindi già dalle 5 6mila avanti cristo e
si pensa siano addirittura serviti a far
aumentare la popolazione a quei tempi a
creare un vero e proprio boom di nascite
di
sopravvivenza soprattutto perché già
utilizzano dei latti animali oltre a
quelli umani e questa cosa è molto
interessante perché ci fa capire come
questo progresso da un prodotto
come questo che arriva fino a noi è una
sorta di progettazione continua cioè noi
non progettiamo soltanto in gruppo oggi
ma progettiamo in gruppo in una sorta di
lasso temporale è dilungato che si
estende fino a noi e questa è una cosa
interessante perché ci fa capire che non
è che oggi noi facciamo degli oggetti ma
in realtà è l'uomo che fa oggetti il
gruppo di persone non è il gruppo di
oggi è la storia che crea gli oggetti
questo vaso è lo stesso oggi mostra
sullo stesso principio
già vediamo questo è un vaso del 6 mil
avanti cristo
già vediamo un manico cioè quindi già
utilizzavano degli strumenti in maniera
efficiente ok se aggiungiamo il manico
porterò meglio questo vaso e c'erano già
degli elementi ornamentali come questi
segni che vediamo queste decorazioni che
vediamo l'esterno che aiutavano comunque
ad inserire l'oggetto maniera più
decorativa all'interno dell'ambiente
domestico domestico a quei tempi
arriviamo a oggi questo è un prodotto
che abbiamo disegnato nel 2020
vedete come la funzione la stessa che
cosa cambia in questo prodotto
cambiano le tecnologie qua c'è di
produzione per produrre un oggetto su
scala industriale per milioni di persone
questo è un oggetto prodotto i milioni
di pezzi
all'esterno è fatto in plastica
totalmente riciclata all'interno invece
la parte bianca che vedete è fatta in
plastica vergine a questo progetto in
questo caso collaborano tante figure
ingegneri meccanici esperti di materiali
esperti di produzione qui c'è anche un
pino
questo video ci mostra come oggi alla
presentazione il gruppo presentazione a
pezzi e da tante persone hanno
partecipato soltanto
la vita umana è umano ma partecipi anche
una macchina cross e l'intelligenza
artificiale cioè quindi quello che prima
riuscivamo a fare portando avanti
la macchina
arrivare
non riuscivamo e poi togliamo una parte
di lavoro molto allenante alla forza
umana che questa è una cosa molto
interessante il futuro probabilmente
sarà molto più verso questa direzione
dove noi progetteremo è sempre più
insieme alle macchine e intelligenza
artificiale per creare prodotti sempre
più sofisticati
una specie di convergenza cioè la cosa
importante è che quando si arriva a fare
questi prodotti si sente proprio che c'è
una convergenza dei saperi dove la
tecnologia e l'innovazione arrivare a un
certo punto di fusione che fanno
arrivare alla produzione di alcuni
prodotti questa questa cosa si sente
moltissimo nell'elettronica guardate
queste immagini che è un'immagine che
mostra una radio degli anni quaranta a
quei tempi la radio era l'unico media
all'interno della casa era una specie di
totem stava lì era il centro della casa
diffondeva idee diffondeva parole musica
questo è un prodotto invece che abbiamo
fatto nel 2014 guardate è uno speaker
bluetooth che addirittura tu puoi
indossare
l'evoluzione tecnologica ci ha permesso
di creare un oggetto piccolissimo che tu
porti con te la tua musica ovunque e
sempre con te questo progetto è stato
fatto da noi progettato una nuova in
italia per un'azienda di parigi con una
fede in cina dove c'era
l'industrializzazione e la produzione
quindi tutto era stato fatto tramite
email un mare di mail prototipi
scambiati tramite corriere
oggi è quello che facciamo
quotidianamente no chiaramente questa
cosa fu un lavoro importante perché
effettivamente io non avevo mai visto
gli ingegneri che stavano in cina dal
vivo questo ci fa capire come oggi
quella tribù che abbiamo visto
all'inizio sia diventata una tribù senza
più un limite spaziale è una tribù che
ha come unico limite l'etere cioè siamo
tutti è una tribù che è diventata
davvero globale
il design e abbiamo detto il lavoro di
squadra ma come funziona un progetto che
facciamo con un'azienda
solitamente noi riceviamo dall'azienda
un brief il brief fatto dalla ricerca e
sviluppo che già un team di persone
cercano quali saranno i prossimi
progetti dell'azienda
facendo delle analisi di mercato
cercando di capire in tour e intuire
quali saranno i prodotti bisogni del
futuro noi iniziamo in studio già un
altro team di persone ad analizzare
questo brief ea buttare giù delle idee
facendo delle ricerche
approfondite facendo viaggi cercando di
capire qual è la direzione giusta da
prendere facciamo degli schizzi che
iniziano a dare un significato al
prodotto per creare dei dettagli
meccanici tagli di materiale iniziamo a
mettere giù anche dei dei concetti
su modelli no cerchiamo di capire
tramite il modello se questo prodotto
funziona arrivando a questo questo ad
esempio modellino di un letto che
abbiamo fatto
facciamo anche dei disegni
tridimensionali al computer e aiutandoci
con l'intelligenza appunto artificiale
se questa cosa ci piace e funziona diamo
tutto all'azienda
se l'azienda dice che quella cosa va
bene e qui entra in gioco ancora un
gruppo più grande di persone si passa a
una prototipazione più grande cioè scala
uno a uno e entrano altre figure la
ricerca e sviluppo dell'azienda i
prototipisti gli ingegneri meccanici
tutti insieme cerchiamo di mettere
appunto questo prodotto seguendo le
linee guida che ci eravamo prefissati
cercando il confort cercando i materiali
più giusti abbinamenti più giusti
e poi per arrivare a questo che il
prodotto finito questo prodotto che
vedete è un letto è stato fotografato da
un fotografo da un team di esperti
grafici e stato impaginato e
sono stati creati dei cataloghi è andato
a finire in fiera e e poi nei negozi
capite che dall'inizio alla fine di
questo processo ci sono decine di
persone che hanno lavorato al prodotto
in questa cosa molto interessante per
capire come oggi funziona un prodotto
industriale che trovate nei negozi
dinamica riferimenti se esiste come
abbiamo detto all'inizio una
sedimentazione
del sapere esiste anche una dinamica di
questa sedimentazione ritorniamo a un
confronto con la natura
pensiamo al fiume il fiume quella è una
cosa che parte dall'inizio alla fine e
crea una sedimentazione lungo il suo
percorso l'acqua porta dai sedimenti
creando la natura stessa del fiume e la
fauna e la flora del fiume crea il letto
del fiume
se noi interrompiamo il corso d'acqua ad
un certo punto
artificialmente a valle di quel corso
avremo un cambiamento incredibile
peggiorativo della qualità delle acque
della qualità della fauna della flora
del fiume e questo è una cosa che durerà
finché questo questa interruzione
esprimerà stabile questa cosa per dirvi
che come la sedimentazione naturale la
sedimentazione del sapere funziona allo
stesso modo se noi oggi creiamo un
interruzione
o ci sono degli errori in quello che
facciamo che progettiamo questi errori
si ripercuotono nel futuro se
percuoteranno nel futuro cioè in pratica
quello che voglio dirvi è che non esiste
il tratto di un fiume esiste il fiume e
non esiste il fiume esiste l'oceano
è una cosa importante questa per dire
che bisogna progettare insieme per un
futuro migliore grazie
[Applauso]